the leaders and government
Representatives who gathered in Havana
represent 80 percent of the world's
population and 49 of its GDP without
exception they vowed to join forces to
strengthen the voice and power of the
global South ahead of next week's U.N
General Assembly meeting
the United Nations the Breton wood
system and the WTO are losing
credibility we must remain United the
giant multinationals of the technology
sector possess a business model that
accentuates the concentration of wealth
the key focus of the 134 members of the
g77 plus China was the world's
asymmetric access to science technology
and Innovation
it is indisputable that Science and
Technology have become key to
development we call on the Secretary
General of the UN to call for a special
session on this during the general
assembly next week
countries with access to Science and
Technology such as China Singapore and
India made commitments to Greater
solidarity and cooperation with those
who are lagging behind
excellencies where there is a political
will reforming multilateralism is
possible
Madam president I'm happy to report that
India has made a choice to deploy
science technology and innovation in its
development policy interventions the
delegates expressed their condolences to
Morocco and to Libya they also called
for an end to the ongoing U.S economic
embargo against Cuba
there was also a call in the final
document for medium and large economies
to do more to bridge the digital Gap the
Declaration of Havana
of its 76
Accord
and called for the quote establishment
of a new world economic order many in
fact compared it to the Titanic saying
that we are all on the same ship and
that if it sinks everyone will perish
together Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Havana
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera